皆さんゴールデンウィーク如何お過ごしでしょうか
去年もやったんですけどもゴールデンウィークは僕はなぜかこう一人でふらっと旅を
するっていう動画去年も出したのでそうしてもちょっとそういうテンションで僕の
ゴールデンウィークを満喫したいわけですよ俺の日か満喫したい理由なのでちょっと今
からフラットずっと外に出て静岡で一人旅をしてくれると思います
たぶん去年池ダム
する人からね分かると思うんですけども
特に面白くないです得に面白くないんですけどただ僕がにふらっとああ
今後ただ僕がふらっと旅するだけなんでまあたまには骨や歯が木の根スピンオフ動画を
取ろうと思いまして早速ぐ
入ってくれる近藤普通に外ってて散歩するだけだから
が入ってきます
まずそれだけだから気ん
re おおおおおおおおおお
wh
母は
いってっ
今から行く久能山っていう山があるんですけども
コードやマニッシュに登ることになりました
ちょっと作りますも2人だとも多分全然もう緊張もせずに学園登れるんだよ
思っていきましょう者に久能山ナチュラです
あじゃあかなり寒いなぁ結構久々です
なんだか不崩れ4+決定だねちょっとちょっと恥ずかしくなっちゃっぱ
というわけで昨日山の近くにつきましたがありましてましたが
1女1ビルメンタルに入ってるけどクローザーの近くにつきました
入り口はこんな感じです
久能山頭像ぶっていうのはう
難関です
歴史的な立てます
ってなんかこのねずっとねぇあるんですけどここずっと登っていく感じになります
者と思っていきましょうねこれどーってことないですか
いや結構機はスイスよ足場と悪いずよね結構凝っからずっと嗅いだなんですけどもって
結構
2位
けど僕は今一人じゃないか
後ろに羊さんが付いているそしてこの動画を見ている君たちもまた
ん
ついてきてるそう
俺はん
一人じゃないいや同い年いけないかと思ったかなんですか
ん
こんな感じでずっと歩いていきますようわこいやぁーなる
から全部無効
黒田
ツッコミられるだろうかと花井ん
思います
ん
voodoo 本
me
f 5
あっそ
ジャミ上がりなんですよ
ああああああ
me
もう少しでゴールです
じゃーん
伝わるだろうこの汗の量これが伝わるでわかりが出るねあ
打つか言ってないここから見る景色がと3つマン綺麗です
こんなガンズでございま静岡の意味が
水滸いたドラマチックに見れるっていう苦悩座の上はこんな感じになっております
ああああああ
me
ん
んうぃーん
yeah yeah
me
ふーん